the winter season's been a banger you've
got the usual suspects you know the
blockbusters that we always knew were
going to be blockbusters however there
have also been some surprising
contenders too anyone expected my
dress-up darling to become as popular as
it turned out to be i guess with a
charismatic female lead in a healthy
dose of fan service anything is possible
still if you thought the winter was big
you haven't seen anything yet the spring
lineup doesn't seem to have a show that
can rival aot or demon slayer in terms
of being big hits but looking at the
overall lineup i actually see an
arguably deeper selection than what
we've got now so yeah you better get
ready because the fun's not about to end
anytime soon
however before we begin how about having
a treat that's right today's video is
brought to you by sakurako sakurako's a
nifty subscription box full of your
favorite sweets and japanese snacks
sakurako seeks to spread the joy of
japanese sweets and tea ceremony culture
through these top-notch boxes so now
even if you live miles away from japan
you can still have the japanese
experience inside your home for only a
reasonably cheap subscription fee you
get your monthly dose of japanese snacks
by the best creators from all over japan
these things truly bring the taste of
japan to your doorstep and you couldn't
ask for a more authentic and enjoyable
glimpse into japanese tea time than with
what sakurako will be bringing you that
i can attest to personally with my
experience and i really love their
recent books this month's box theme is
sakura afternoon tea and you can enjoy a
hanami picnic at your home as an aside i
also find it pretty cool that the box
doesn't just contain japanese snacks it
also has kitchenware you know so check
out the link in the description box and
use code vinnie to get five dollars off
your first box delightful snacks pretty
looking boxes and useful kitchenware
what's not to like get your sakuranco
subscriptions now
[Applause]
we kick things off with a sports show
the newest football sensation oh
is it just me or is there a lack of
soccer themed shows i can think of
captain tsubasa and the upcoming blue
lock but it's sorely missing that one
title that everyone will think of when
it comes to a certain sport like kuroko
or slam dunk haikyuu ippo prince of
tennis that sort of title awashi frankly
speaking doesn't seem to be on that
trajectory still it's a show that sports
fans should definitely look forward to
awashi's a very interesting sports anime
because instead of the usual
inter-school settings it's a show that
goes beyond schools and starts dabbling
on the actual big leagues it's a tale of
determination and redemption that
creates an atmosphere that's familiar
yet ultimately different after all this
one's all about facing your weakness as
compared to the most external challenges
sports anime gives our heroes awashi
starts off looking like a series about
overcoming adversity and turning
disappointments into paths of greatness
typical sports aesops if you ask me
whether it will etch its name as one of
the next big sports titles well that
remains to be seen but i'm definitely
looking forward to it still
in the ninth night is tomodachi game
here's something i've taken some
interest in for some time now donald
dyche game if you were to ask me to
quickly describe it feels a bit like
danganronpa or quite frankly a lot of
those edgy trust and betrayal games
friends forced to play a high-stakes
game when there's a hidden antagonist
and they experience the gradual
fracturing of their seemingly
all-powerful bonds seems to be the niche
edgy hit of the season well not quite as
violent as the titles that have had that
description you know like platinum end
darwin's game battle in five seconds
liar game and such like that i can
guarantee that donald dyche game can
bring about the same type of vibes these
shows have having read the manga i also
like how cleverly the games get thought
out and it was a joy seeing the
characters express themselves throughout
the games looking to be a cult hit this
season domination game could be your jam
at number eight is summertime render
[Music]
it's about time for one of those shows
again time travel the chance to redo
what you did wrong in exchange for the
chance of a happy ending the first few
preview picks may not give off this
impression but summertime render is one
hell of a thrilling adventure using the
time travel through death concept the
premise is simple shadows threaten to
doom an island and shinpei must use his
powers of time travel to find the root
cause of the destruction and save
everyone as for how this is different
from something like erased or re-zero
i'd gladly say that summertime render
has won up the titles by eventually
introducing higher stakes and
limitations to the power marking the
race to the finish line a very exciting
run that i can't put down indeed it's a
manga that i binged on in a couple of
days so i'm very high on this title i
hope that the anime version just does it
justice too seven is the next season of
one of my favorite harems data live
[Music]
third time's the charm i guess
originally slated to air as early as
late 2021 dataline's fourth season had a
rough going two delays but it looks like
we're all set for it to go this spring
with this being the fourth installment
of a franchise i guess it's better to
talk about the premise from the get-go
basically think something like world god
only knows but with lots of badass
powers and battles data live is a fun
series that combines some crazy elements
that somehow work so well together the
dating sim thing the harem the chuni
fights it's a show that's emblematic of
what the scene was like in the early
2010s and i'm so glad it's still going
strong to this day this season now takes
the team to the next two spirits as
shido tries to solve the puzzle of love
with spirits near and muguru the last
few revelations about the world begin to
unfold as the show begins to head
towards the end game one that would
honestly take around another season or
two now i didn't expect to get this far
honestly four seasons for a franchise
with moderate international popularity
is a lot things are about to heat up
afterwards though so let's cross our
fingers for a full adaptation date of
life fever is still going strong in asia
so i'm keeping my hopes up
next at number six on the list is
shikimori's not just a cutie
[Music]
imagine yourself being this unfortunate
guy coming home every day with nothing
but disappointment only one thing can
save you right yep i'm talking about the
perfect girlfriend shikimori in a lot of
ways is that confident faithful athletic
and caring not to mention a complete
beauty too but how would you deal with a
girlfriend who can also be so cool in
the most frightening way possible yes
it's the seasonal rom-com that pairs a
mismatched couple opposites do attract
and having read some of the manga i can
say that seeing the beta and shy male
character interact with this very
commanding beauty of a girlfriend is a
joy it's a very enjoyable slice of life
and i'll put some slight yandere alerts
out for you shikimori comes to us this
april it's still too early to tell but
i'm seeing this as a sleeper hit of the
season
this one surprised me i knew everyone
was waiting for kami-san and it's one of
the best shows of its season so i was a
bit bummed that it split core but we
don't have to wait any longer as we'll
finally have the continuation of this
sweet school comedy and i think it
deserves it the first season is a very
fun and cute comedy that hoists up the
social anxiety angle as its hook and it
works spectacularly the episodes while
some being slow in actual developments
were never a chore to watch as the
characters are so charming and engaging
i'd also love to give a shout out to the
series production qualities with its
visuals and sounds will we see more of
the same in season two will we get more
developments in the relationship between
komi and tadano all signs are pointing
to a resounding yes and i'm really
looking forward to it
fourth on our list today is the movie
bubble
[Music]
i've talked about this before and as its
release nears i've retained those
positive impressions for bubble a
brainchild of some of the brightest
minds in the industry bubble in my
thought is a movie showcasing youthful
energy taking place in a tokyo that's
been isolated the movie deals with
people who've since taken up parkour to
battle each other jumping from building
to building it's also the story of a
fated meeting between parkour prodigy
hibiki and uttar a girl with powers it's
hard not to get excited with the trailer
that's dropped the whole thing just
looks breathtakingly beautiful and i
like how the art and animation managed
to capture the thrill of a sport such as
parkour the plot itself doesn't seem to
be anything unique but as i always say
execution is king in these kinds of
things will it be able to ride the hype
into becoming the best standalone anime
movie in 2022 it's honestly too early to
tell but the potential is there and with
these amazing creators at the helm
anything can happen
ah shield hero it's an isakai that i
really liked people looked forward to it
and it had its fair share of
controversies back then funny to think
that what shield hero had to go through
is pretty much child's play compared to
the stuff that's happened to other
titles since then but i digress overall
shield heroes a nice isakai that mainly
thrives on the dynamic of its lead party
the first season was a joy to watch not
only due to the redemption arc and the
payoff which is covered in a satisfying
moments video of mine by the way so
check that out but also because of how
nao fumi and raphtalia grow and play off
each other as characters i'm very
excited for the second season because
after the ride that was the kalmira
island arc we'll be seeing the team take
on the spirit turtle oh some cool people
from the past will also be making a much
awaited return as powerful allies i
won't spoil it for you but i'm sure some
of you can already guess who that might
just be
our second most anticipated anime of the
season is spy family
talk about a show of wacky elements spy
family is quite the wild one putting
together three peculiar individuals in a
pretend family or for the sake of their
missions a spy an assassin and a psychic
girl this short looks like a recipe for
a lot of fun adventures ahead both in
their respective assignments and trying
to keep their identities a secret
besides the setup i find watching this
family go through their mundane lives to
be very entertaining you see they may be
specialists in their fields when it
comes to everyday stuff they tend to be
some of the most hilariously clueless
and oblivious people out there
surprisingly wholesome and very funny
spy family is the action comedy that we
all needed people are awaiting its grand
debut into the anime world and
rightfully so probably gonna be the best
new anime this season will have to offer
and the rest of the gang are back at it
again with the third season this time
subtitled gaguyasama ultraromantic it's
been quite a long road for kaguyasama
but with all these anime seasons and the
immense popularity that doesn't look to
be waning anytime soon it's safe to say
that kaguyasama is probably the iconic
rom-com of this generation the galaxy
brain battle between our two leads has
enthralled anime fans worldwide and
things just keep getting crazier with
each season new characters get
introduced new developments turn the
status quo over its head and there's a
lot of fun to be had we still see many
exciting arcs and segments from the
manga to see animated the third season
we'll have a lot more of that after all
things are starting to heat up with the
relationship between our leads who will
be the breakout star character of this
season there's only one way to find out
and that's by tuning into the third
season of this hit rom-com
do you have gaguyasama as your most
anticipated title this spring season or
is it spy family whatever it is i'd love
to know your reason so head on down to
the comments section to have a little
chat about it if you're interested in
connecting through social media however
you can check out my instagram patreon
and channel memberships which also help
support the channel financially so i'd
love you to check those out as well
don't forget to check out our sponsors
soccer uncle if you're up for
experiencing authentic japanese snacks
links in the description that's it for
this video i hope that you'll have a
good day ahead of you and let's look
forward to what's looking to be an
exciting spring season
[Music]
you